I'm on a quest to buy every Harry Potter
video game that's ever been released
I'll need to collect 39 total games that
were developed over a two decade span
dating all the way back to 2001 and
currently I only own five of them that
means we'll need to track down titles
across four generations of video games
from the original PlayStation to Game
Boy Color and yeah even the Obscure
titles like Harry Potter for connect and
the PS3 wonderbook games so I recently
set out on an adventure to track down
all of these games
all right so
let's find the old school oh my goodness
oh my goodness you cannot make this up
you cannot make this up literally guys
the first thing I see right there
Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire
7.99 for the original Xbox the tricky
part about collecting games from this
series is that unlike Goblet of Fire
many of the other titles were different
between platforms sometimes with a
completely different developer entirely
as was the case with the original Harry
Potter and the Philosopher's Stone oh
and there's also the handheld versions
but more on those in a bit dude they
have the original duck hunt are you
kidding me let's go score okay PS2 oh my
goodness and we also have Half Blood
Prince they also had Order of the
Phoenix for PS2 but at home I already
have ordered the Phoenix for the PS3
this is the one that I'm undecided on
afla Prince I don't think it's an
incredibly rare one but I don't really
want it for the PS2 because it was also
out for the PS3 which I'm sure is going
to be a much better version of the game
they did not have a lot of handheld
games at all not many PlayStation games
I looked through those too I mean just
early on I really feel like that
original philosopher's stone for
PlayStation PC games and then those
wonder book and the connect game yeah I
feel like those are going to be pretty
hard to get hello how are you
our next stop was Game Exchange and it
was a big step up in terms of the sheer
amount of games across so many
generations that's also where I met
summer I told her about all the games I
was looking for and she was so
incredibly helpful she immediately
started looking for games and even
called other stores in the area to see
what they had unfortunately even after
searching through all of their handheld
games I didn't find any Harry Potter
titles some were thought she remembered
seeing a copy of quidditch World Cup
recently but neither of us could find it
here I did manage to find two copies of
Harry Potter for connect though both
games complete in their original box I
also noticed they had a copy of Half
Blood Prince for the 360 but not in the
original box they even had a copy of
2003 sorcerer Stone remake for the Xbox
but it was like 43 dollars and no
original box Summer's call to the other
stores paid off too one of the stores
about half an hour away said they
definitely had a copy of Chamber of
Secrets for the Game Boy Color and
possibly more so we're heading over
there now even though we've spent gosh I
don't know three four hours at this so
far and we only have two games I still
feel way more encouraged than I did at
the start of it there are people out
there like summer and game stores out
there who are willing to help you out
when you're looking for something very
very specific like this you guys are not
gonna believe what happened on the way
over here how do I put this as I'm
driving down the road out of the corner
of my eye I see something crawl
something very large very hairy
something with eight legs I mean we are
on our way to pick up a Chamber of
Secrets all the spiders am I right
hello how's it going
uh summer called about the Harry Potter
games yeah nice
here I met Boone and Pierce two other
awesome Associates who helped me out
with the games not only did they have
chamber of seekers for Game Boy Color
Pierce was able to find a copy of
Sorcerer's Stone as well Chamber of
Secrets for the GameCube and even
Sorcerer's Stone for the PS1
unfortunately only the PS1 game included
the original box and cover art and
that's when Pierce told me about the
cover project I don't think I even knew
this existed I have never seen this
before the
coverproject.net alright so we would
need the one for GameCube and would you
look at that there it is so I decided to
take that chance and ended up purchasing
all four games right then and there now
time for some lunch I still cannot
believe the Taco Bell tried to take away
this glorious Mexican pizza why would
you ever want to take this away from the
people
whatever happened to sporks ma'am can we
bring back this works Taco Bell just a
fantastic utensil our first day of
searching honestly went even better than
I expected I had six games from the list
and that was before even starting to
search online one thing I didn't see a
lot of during my in-person search though
PC games so I hopped on eBay that night
and snagged five more games all PC
versions the original Philosopher's
Stone Chamber of Secrets Prisoner of
Azkaban and even copies of Lego Creator
Harry Potter and Lego Creator Harry
Potter in the Chamber of Secrets all in
all day one felt like a huge success I
had the original five games we started
with plus six from my in-person search
and then five more from eBay which
brought us up to 16 out of the 39 games
we needed almost halfway there already
we should be able to knock this out in
just another day or two right right my
name's Jonathan and I was in one of your
other stores yesterday and you guys were
so helpful trying to help me track down
a few very specific games and they
didn't have them here so I wanted to
know if I could just kind of either send
you this list or I can just go through
it here over the phone with you whatever
is easier for you to see if you guys
have them there so my plan had been to
call the other Game Exchange store which
was about two and a half hours away
summer had mentioned they usually have a
lot of games and thought there was a
decent chance they would have some of
the ones we needed
foreign
honestly you guys I'm a little bit
discouraged right now I thought that
call this afternoon was definitely going
to go a different way certainly didn't
expect them to have every single game
but for them to come back and not have
any game I've also been sitting here on
my laptop reviewing through the list
again unfortunately looks like there are
even more games that I need to get
specifically with the handheld Games
summer had told me about another local
game shop that might have some of the
games I was looking for and I made that
my first stop the very next day yeah
they're they're closed
says they open at 12 at 1205.
I decided to try another half-price
bookstore and three Goodwill stores I
got really excited for a fraction of a
second in one of the Goodwill stores
when I saw this but yeah it was just the
movies even though I was discouraged I
remembered the folks at Game Exchange
had been so helpful so far so why not
check yet another nearby Game Exchange
store and that's when things started to
turn around there I found a copy of
Sorcerer's Stone for the Game Boy
Advance then I remembered two things
about the very first store on the very
first day of our adventure they had a
copy of Half Blood Prince for the 360
and also an Xbox copy of the 2003
sorcerer Stone game I thought it was way
too expensive but after looking online
it actually looked like they had a very
decent price for it unfortunately it
just didn't have the original box and
manual but now that I knew about the
cover project yeah you guys see where
I'm going here so on my way back home I
stopped by and snagged the copy of Half
Blood Prince for the 360 and the Xbox
copy of Sorcerer's Stone then I spent
the night shopping for the best deals I
could find all the while making sure I
was dealing with trustworthy Sellers and
the next day things started looking up
[Music]
dad the games are here
foreign
[Music]
and I'm looking for what seems to be a
really hard to find PS3 game and I just
wanted to check to see if you guys had
it it's called Wonder book book of
potions for the PlayStation 3.
good
foreign
wow okay guys good news and bad news
here there's a game that I cannot find
it's book of potions Harry Potter or
excuse me wonder book book of potions
doesn't even have Harry Potter in the
title so we probably could have just
removed it from this challenge I have
searched online I've searched in stores
I've call around various places and the
ones that I found on eBay they're all
very highly priced and I can't find any
us editions the good news we have
completed everything except for both
Wonder Book Games wonder book book of
spells wonder book book of potions but
here's the really good news though one
of our community members shout out to
Rin by the way thank you so much Ren
reached out and said they had a sealed
copy a book of spells plus some
additional things they wouldn't tell me
what it's a surprise I'm here at UPS
we're getting ready to go inside I'm
almost positive that this is the package
from our community member wren a sealed
copy of book of spells
and some other mystery items we don't
know Rin wouldn't tell us so I'm gonna
go inside and then we're gonna unbox
this thank you have a good one
[Music]
these people love the internet
foreign
[Music]
so I think this might be my first time
ever definitely my first time ever
holding this box I'm sure I saw it in
stores at some point Miranda goshok book
of spells bringing Wizardry to life in
your living room this is a very special
moment man we only have one game left
book of potions is the last thing we
need now that we have this copy book of
spells I think you guys I think I may
have found the copy we had to go across
the pond to our friends in the UK no I
didn't actually go over there we ordered
a copy supposed to be in the box like
this the only problem is I have no idea
when it's going to arrive well I've
discovered another problem so remember
the site we've been talking about the
cover project I think we just got lucky
with the first couple games that we
tried because I've been going back and
they do not have everything so they had
the first couple games that I tried so I
thought oh we're good I ordered a bunch
of games now I'm starting to see that
they don't have all of them so man yeah
I if we can make some ourselves
[Music]
foreign
okay while we are waiting for the game
to arrive there's one more thing I need
to do how many donuts
uh yes I'll do a dozen six glazed and
six chocolate please there you go
appreciate it have a good one I also
wanted to do a little something extra
special for summer since she was really
the first person that actually kind of
went out of their way to help me out
with this so we have Hogwarts Legacy the
art and making a sealed copy there and
then also thanks to Rin for hooking us
up with all of these extra Hogwarts
Legacy what do they call these like 10
poster yeah so it's like a little
collectible tin poster I think these
were available at GameStop I come bring
in gifts
yeah yeah so this is for everybody here
just wanted to give you guys something
for being so helpful I appreciate it and
then I got this for you remember you
liked Hogwarts so that's the art book
sealed and everything
and then one of my viewers actually sent
this to me so it's like a 10 poster so
there's that and then some stickers here
some retro stickers for you to do that
thank you yeah no problem just wanted to
do a little something for you because
you you were like the first person that
I met doing this and you yeah you like
really went out of your way and so it's
just really cool so I appreciate it this
is awesome
you guys she was so surprised man that
was awesome summer Summer's just the
best every gaming store needs somebody
like summer unfortunately she told me
she's not gonna be here for too much
longer because she's actually going to
be working out of one of the offices
instead it's kind of amazing that this
all happened at the time when it did and
that we were able to meet up with her
and she's been so helpful on this
journey so now we just have to wait we
just have to wait and see when book of
potions is gonna get here hopefully soon
oh my goodness you guys okay this is
literally weeks after it has been a
while it took a little bit longer than I
was hoping but finally it has arrived
we're gonna open it find out and then I
will finally reveal the complete
collection for you guys to see
[Music]
foreign
if you'd like to see gameplay in more
details about how these games are very
different from one another then check
out the video on the right side of your
screen now for my complete history of
the Harry Potter video games as always
thank you all so much for watching I'll
talk to you again soon